instagram est en train d'effacer
énormément de comptes c'est géant c'est
massif c'est jamais arrivé c'est arrivé
à ma compagne qui m'appelle et qui me
dit Aurélien mon compte a été supprimé
je peux plus rien faire je peux pas le
récupérer qu'est-ce qui se passe et
quand vous faites vos recherches vous
tombez sur quoi un article du Parisien
notamment qui vous explique un bug
mondial entraîne une suspension
aléatoire et géante des comptes aller
donc voir tout de suite sur Instagram si
votre compte n'a pas été supprimé comme
on se parle ici d'un bug je suis sûr que
Instagram de toute façon des sauvegardes
ils vont réactiver tous les comptes mais
en attendant ceux qui ont été impactés
ne peuvent plus se connecter ne peuvent
plus rien faire et je pense que pour
certains et notamment des comptes
professionnels ça doit être la panique
aller voir si votre compte a été
supprimé et dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires et pour plus d'infos et
d'actu concernant la tech pensez à vous
abonner